on today's show we talked to a young mom
who's wrestling between home school
and public school for her six-year-old
we talked to a mom whose 24 year old son
still lives at home and he probably
should not anymore
we talked to a woman who is wrestling
with boundaries and her parents
and her siblings who still live at home
it's a heartbreaker
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what up what up good folks i'm john
and this is the dr
john galone show
the show that i selfishly named after
myself i didn't really do that but
every time it it just makes me laugh hey
listen thanks for hanging out on the
show we're going to talk about your
mental health
your life your friends your family
and for some reason whenever the show
starts i growl i don't even know why
that happens
we're gonna talk about your life no
we're not we're gonna talk about your
life
and your friends and your community like
like uh
i usually smoke about 30 smokes before
um
this show actually launches and so i
like to make it sound like i'm tough
and a little bit yelly and i don't even
know why that happens it's so dumb
give us a call if you want to be on the
show 1-844-693-3291
somebody james just was like their
buddies been hassling them to listen to
the show
in the first eight seconds they already
were like nope we're out
already gone but for those of you who's
hung in there all
37 of you and if you if you can do math
we've we've tripled our audience in the
last few weeks we're up 37
1-844-693-3291
and i want everybody to know this if
you're watching this on
on the internets or if you're listening
to it i'm wearing a blue plaid shirt
i came into the studio i've got like
this this group of clothes back there
this group of clothes because they're
people i have
um like a set of clothes back there for
different events i mean when you're on
like you know news stations you gotta
dress like
this type of idiot and when you're on
like somebody else's show you gotta
dress like this type of [ __ ] i mean you
an ig live song you gotta dress like
this
and then on this show i can just wear
the clothes i normally wear
but heaven for bed good folks i grabbed
a uh
like i grabbed a a polo shirt not and
not even a little horse on it like a
like a generic
11 polo 11 i just lied to you all
everybody it was six dollars
and it was black and james walked in and
he's like oh gosh are you okay
and i was like i think so because why
are you wearing that you're embarrassing
yourself and your family by wearing that
are you going golfing after this what's
happening right then kelly walked in
and she's like oh are you are you sick
are you okay
and to which i was like guys can i just
wear a shirt with no sleeves
and kelly's like nope you actually you
can't you look ridiculous so i went and
changed
into and now you perfectly blend in with
the background screen hey
that is a y'all's fault zach is gonna
have to put on some lasers or
whatever like psychedelic backgrounds or
something
funrunner.com.net.org
www.funrunner.
ah geez this is why i got into mental
health because people that i associate
with
hurt mine is that a thing can you can
you hurt mine
look at you guys no one's gonna make fun
of y'all's polos none of y'all wearing
polos
jerks i hope to everyone out there
wearing a polo
you're loved
[Laughter]
you're not that's the problem don't wear
polos
just don't deserve it's getting well
you're worth getting well you polo wears
you
you folks you wear uh collared shirts
with no sleeves
i mean with part sleeves that's
ridiculous all right
um so if you are new to the show and you
haven't already rolled off yet
like dude this is ridiculous i'm going
to rogan or banjoko's podcast this is
terrible
um if you're still with us we're glad
you're here um
start singing your favorite song and
we're going to go straight to the phones
here uh
let's go to ashley in oklahoma city
ashley what in the world are you doing
how's it going
um i'm better now listening to your
whole polo story i feel a little bit
better about myself
are you wearing a polo right now no i'm
not because you're better than that
right
hey literally ashley i was about to say
what are you wearing and i thought this
isn't that kind of show it was the whole
thing was going sideways
so i'm just gonna trust you that you're
not wearing a polo and then we're just
gonna roll from there
what's up ashley from oklahoma how can i
help
yeah i would like help um deciding on if
i should send my
six-year-old to public school or just
homeschool her
okay tell me about it what's going on
what are you thinking
um whenever i was pregnant
all of that i i was dead set on
homeschooling
and then i realized that i'm not very
social myself
[Laughter]
so i can do all of the academic stuff
all of that but i'm
i'm not very good at letting her play
with other kids or
meeting moms to play with other kids um
and i guess i uh i get i just don't do
it myself
okay you don't like other people i mean
i do
but i have a younger daughter and i
don't like having to
wrestle both of them
but yeah i now i'm thinking about
public school and i feel like it would
be a better option i'm just
still nervous about that what are you
nervous about
um she's very i don't want her to
her innocence to go away and her to be
exposed to
things that she wouldn't be if she were
at home okay
um and just the pressure that school
will bring i wanted to stay young as
as long as possible i guess gotcha
so what do you think is going to happen
in a public school like what type of
exposure are you worried about or what
type of pressure are you worried about
because you're talking about like
kindergarten at this point right yes
so in between learning how to count and
read what type of
what type of pressure are you thinking
of
uh well my mind it automatically goes to
bad things but
tell me what the bad things are learn
about sex and learn about body parts and
learn swear words
and learn like watch somebody get
punched like what are the things that
you're worried about
no more of my niece she was exposed to
pornography at seven
from school that and her just worrying
about what other people think
not having that confidence in herself or
starting to be insecure
okay all of that which i don't know if
it happens at kindergarten or not but
i mean it happens everywhere
here's here's my thought on okay um we
went through this same
scenario here in my house um i'm a big
big big believer in public schools love
them love them
love them and over the last five to ten
years
i hate with all of my guts
this paranoid obsession
with technology in schools
if we don't get them this chromebook
this device
this thing this ipad then they're going
to be so far behind and they're going to
fall apart and the world's going to be
and schools across the country are
spending billions of dollars on
on like gadgets for kids
it's not learning right um and i know
there's some
tech ed folks some edtech folks who want
to go to fight me on it that's fine i'd
love to
i'd love to meet up with you on it
that's a different phone call
but i'm a big believer in public schools
the teachers many of the teachers are
are extraordinarily underselling them
their magic
what they do and they get up every day
thinking about our kids there are crappy
teachers out there no question about
that
here's here's my thought on it your
kid over time is going to be exposed to
is going to hear bad words is going to
learn wild things about sex that are so
like are anatomically impossible but
that's how they're going to figure it
out right
they're going to learn weird things
about how people do christmas
differently and
why does your mom look like that and why
does your dad have
like they're gonna learn those things
where i landed
personally in our home is i want them to
have those experiences
and those questions in my house
i want to cultivate a
spirit or an ethos of communication on
our house i want to
um like cultivate hey tell me about
something you saw that you'd never seen
before i asked my son the other day i
was like hey what new words have you
learned this year
and he told me the words he learned this
year and
um i was like what do those even mean
i never had that conversation with my
dad but i wanted to teach him a few
things number one
i'm not scared of any question you're
gonna bring me none zero
number two those words coming out of
your mouth lightning doesn't strike you
you don't die
number three they actually have meanings
number four what's the context why would
we say those why wouldn't we say that
right so i want them to
him to be a consumer of the world around
him and
i want to be a safe resource for him and
so
sometimes people take that logic to an
extreme and they say well i want my kids
to get
wasted with all their friends at my
house because i want them to you know i
mean and there's a point where
that gets stupid right the roi and that
gets dumb
um but that's why i am that's why i have
no problem with the public school system
that i happen to be a part of
i do know there's some really rough
public schools out there that aren't any
good so you as
a parent are gonna have to be discerning
about that um i'll tell you on our end
we went and
my wife especially went met with the
teacher met with the counselor met with
everybody when we moved
what's this experience gonna be like and
it was remarkable and we've also been
really loud about
here's what we will accept with
technology when we won't accept the
technology
and so some of that's just being a an
involved and engaged parent
not an idiotic parent but an engaged
parent
how much of this and let me ask you this
because i've experienced this in my own
house
how much of this do you have guilt
that you wanted to be a homeschooler and
it's not working out for you and your
child
um i think that's most of it i feel like
i
should be able to do that um because i'm
her mom
ah there you go i experienced that my
wife experienced that many of our
friends experienced that especially when
kova kicked off
that we were gonna stay at home we're
gonna homeschool this is gonna be great
and then two months in it's like
i just had this image of showing up to
my front porch and my wife's on the
front porch just smoking a cigarette
holding the shovel and i would just know
like what
one of my kids is in the yard right um
it just wasn't going to end well and
then there's all of that compound and
guilt like oh i can't even
be around my own kid i can't right and
all that stuff's unnecessary but it just
piles up on you
um why why
is that seed sitting there in your soul
why is that is that seed taking root
in your heart there um
i'm not really sure i that's kind of how
i feel about a lot of things i just
always put it on
myself
why do you do that to yourself i don't
i don't know so i want to
like i should be able to do
all the things and do them well
so do me a favor tonight okay um
your husband a good guy yes okay
so i want you all to do
an exercise together okay i want you
to sit with him and to write down all of
the things that you quote unquote
should be able to do
and which is just a should list you
should be able to
change all the diapers with a smile on
your face and joy in your heart because
this is your precious baby
you should be able to wash all the skin
marks out of a six-year-old's
underwear because i just love that baby
right
you should be able to never get annoyed
with mommy hey mom
hey mom hey mom right i want you to
write down all of those shoulds
and then i want you and your husband to
go through those and demand evidence
from them like is this true
and my guess is a whole bunch of those
shoulds
have been put there by your parents your
in-laws your your interpretation
of um what
instagram nonsense like this curated
existence that's not real but that we
especially moms beat each other up with
right all you're going to find a lot of
this is just garbage
because my guess is ashley you're a
great great mom
and you love your kid a lot and
you ran into a situation where there's
going to be a professional that's going
to be better
at a particular role and that's awesome
great send your kid to public school
cultivate a conversation that happens
every day
let your teacher know of your kid hey my
seven-year-old
niece or nephew got an easter
pornography that cannot happen with my
child
and it's your responsibility as the
teacher who gave them this tech
to keep that from happening and i'd
rather you see a bulldog
be a bulldog on behalf of your kid then
um
beat yourself up for not being all
things to all people does that make
sense
yeah i want you to be a mom that
delights in the things that she does
well
and is bold and brave enough to pass
along the things that she doesn't do
well and i don't want your
child to ever feel that mom tension that
angst that anxiety because a kid is
gonna backfill that as though it's her
fault and she's gonna try to solve it
yes i see that now sometimes tell me
about that
um well she's the oldest of the two and
she's just
one she just like me perfectionist just
wants to do everything and she's always
saying
i'm trying to do the right thing so i
don't get in trouble and again she's
she's five right now so
so is that how you are
in in other aspects of your life
yeah since i was a kid i was the same
way
who were you protecting at your house my
little sister
who were you trying to please um
i was trying to be noticed by my parents
my mom and dad
my dad wasn't really around so i always
thought it had to
be something for him to be around gotcha
you're going to be extra sparkly and
extra shiny right
yeah is that exhausting yeah
okay so here's what i want you to do i
want you
to stop the performance with your
husband
and stop the performance with your
little baby with your six-year-old
with your new child and i want you to
begin
practicing just being you
and i want you to practice loving and
connecting with that kid
come hell or high water and that starts
with you've heard me say this over and
over it starts with those little bitty
knucklehead things like
every day in the morning and every day
in the evening i'm gonna hold my kids
face and i'm gonna look them in the eyes
and let's say
i love you and i'm so so
so glad that i get to be your mom and
dad
i get to be your mom i got picked to be
your
mom and they'll go ma ma
and when they bring you that paper and
say look the teacher put a check mark on
it
isn't this so good your response is not
yeah that's right or why didn't you get
a check plus the response is
did you work really hard are you proud
of the work that you put into that
and they say yeah i'm proud and say i'm
really proud that you're proud
good for you because we want to praise
their efficacy inside not the
achievement right
and you sound like you're ready to rock
and roll send your kid to public school
be really clear with your husband about
what y'all want at a public school what
you won't tolerate at a public school
and be direct with it and then if you do
it for a year and it's no good
then you can get some more skills when
it comes back to
considering homeschooling again um we've
got close friends who've homeschooled
and they
love it they're incredible at it and
we've got friends who've tried it we
tried it didn't work
didn't work for us and our kids are
absolutely thriving in
the schools that they're at so it's an
individual thing for every family
don't do it because you're scared of my
kid's gonna hear a thing or see a thing
i actually want that especially when
they're in my home i don't want them the
first time they hear something they've
never heard before
to be at a college when they live seven
hours away from me i don't want them the
first time they see something that
scares them
to be eight hours away to college or 17
hours away at a new job
i don't want that i want to have those
experiences when they're with me
so we create that conversation i love
your heart ashley good for you
you've got this you've got this don't
doubt yourself honor yourself and do the
should exercise tonight
with your husband i his eyes are going
to bug out of his head
when he sees the things all written out
that you think you should be doing
as a mom as a wife as just a neighbor
and hopefully you can have some peace
when you mark those things off me like i
shouldn't do that nobody should like
cleaning skid marks it's disgusting
it's awful all right let's go to uh anne
in
bakersfield what's up anne how are you
doing
great thank you dr john and thank you
for taking my call thank you for calling
what's going on
um i have a 24 year old young man
who lives with his dad my husband who
um who i believe is addicted to
pornography
your son is yes and he lives in your
house
yes okay tell me about how that works um
i have evidence of of money coming out
of his account anywhere from five to
twenty dollars
that kind of i traced back um i've told
him like to give me
his phone which he does a couple of
evenings but then
a couple evenings have passed and he
doesn't give me my phone because we go
to bed early because we get up very
early
um he follows girls on instagram he sits
in a common area when i walk by and what
are you doing
um ryan he'll quickly turn the picture
to something else i do have a younger
child
21 living at home so i'm really
concerned that he's picking up on it
he is he doesn't take care of himself
ann why is he living at home he's 24 i
know
well that's the problem and that's why
i'm calling you because it's getting in
the way
of my husband and i relationship
absolutely
i i'm kind of like if i warn him and i
put it out there
let him let him go and my husband is
saying he needs help let's keep him here
and direct him and get him help
what does he need what does he need help
with um we feel like there's depression
there
like he stays he'll stay in his room he
doesn't eat unless it's served for him
or he'll order in
all the time do you hold on hold on hold
on do you serve it
um on the on the on the counter before
i go to bed because i guess i'm a
concerned mom and he will not eat like
he's
no no no no you're not a concerned mom
you're not
you're not i'm an enabler yeah you are
you are getting what you need by taking
care of your little boy
and you've got he has no problems he has
no reason to change
anything in his life at all he's got it
so good
he has food put on the counter he's got
no rent he's got women just piped into
his phone
that challenge him in no ways he's got
money just going from his account
straight he can do whatever he wants
whenever he wants to
and what that leads to is
deep resounding depression
because there's no there's no goal
there's no
achievement there's no working towards
something there's no little steps
there's no success there's no internal
esteem that can only be accomplished not
from telling you someone you're great
but from doing things you've got to go
do and this young man is just drowning
because mom keeps putting water in the
in the bathtub
he's got to have some problems he's got
a great life right now
okay so how can we help him then kick
him out
say go or say
you will go see a counselor you will
have no phone in my house
when there will be zero phones none
and then when we go to bed the internet
goes off and i take the router in my
bedroom
it's out
because if you're not serious about it
you're not serious about it
he's 24.
people you're how old are you han 55
yeah i have i have two other chill i
have a total of four children
ranging from 21 to 27.
what does your 27 year old think about
him just living at home
probably a lot of the same things i'm
telling you too
is he does he have like mental illness
is he struggling have real
like significant challenges um i would
say along the lines of depression
self-esteem for sure um
and he doesn't he doesn't seem to care
like he leaves
his room is filthy i will help help help
him clean him up and he'll go right back
to his old ways he leaves his
in and out burger bag all in the living
room of common area after i've told him
to pick it up
i know i know but you hear what you're
saying as you say it out loud you hear
it i know you do
i do because it doesn't matter he can do
whatever he wants in his room because
his mom's gonna help him come clean it
i'm embarrassed for myself if i have his
other siblings come over to visit us
or friends come over so what is it about
him
i don't want to tell you to kick a guy
out with severe mental illness
if he's schizophrenic if he's bipolar if
he's got some major challenges
if anything depression and i and i've
asked him to see the doc
to see a doctor i can't make it for him
he's 24. yeah he says
he denies having a problem well cool go
get him buddy you got two months left
and you're gonna have a job and you're
out i will change the locks
and you're not doing this because you're
mean you're doing this because you love
your son
or let me let me let me put it this way
you're giving him everything in because
you love him you really
do i believe that is it anything you're
doing helping him
no no is anything getting better
definitely not okay so you got to do
something different
you can't keep doing the same thing
wanting the same outcome
right correct yeah
and either it's cold turkey you got
you got 60 days and you're gone or
it is if you're gonna live here starting
in 60 days you pay rent or i will evict
you
and well he does pay me rent he pays me
425 dollars
does he work phone uh he does four to
five days
a week it's for his phone his cell phone
um story in the groceries and his car
insurance
so 425 barely and then the food what
what is he worth amazon amazon delivery
so he's out making deliveries correct
so what's he do with the rest of his
money just saves it uh he's a saver
we are dave ramsey followers so i will
tell you i've taught him in that respect
and he's really excited about that but
uh hey you know why he gets excited
because it's actual achievements
accomplishment it's things he can see
progressing in his life in a positive
direction
his social life he's not seeing that his
ability to create his own wealth he's
not seeing that
because he's got no home he's got no
equity he's got no things he's working
towards
career advancement he's got nothing
there
oh i agree and he's going to tell you
you're the worst mom
ever he's gonna tell you you guys are
ruining my life i can't believe you're
kicking me out
unbelievable after all you've done and
all you know that's coming and that's
gonna be part of the separation
but until he has any sort of struggle or
any sort of reason to do
anything in his life differently he's
not going to
i wouldn't
right what's your husband think about
this is your husband ashamed or does he
like it
um no he says that we should help him by
keeping
in our house and direct them in certain
ways but uh how is the direction helping
what does your husband say
i'm hard he needs help my husband
struggles with depression so he sort of
feel knows how it feels to feel
the self-esteem and lack of self-esteem
yeah have you ever gone to a family
counselor before
no never yeah maybe you should try that
because you all got to develop some
pretty hard boundaries real real fast
and you got a 21 year old soaking all
this in
so what your 21 year old is is learning
is that mom and dad have no boundaries
and they're gonna it's a they're a gravy
train
for whatever i want to do
so i know you're worried about them
learn your 21 year old learning about
how pornography works like spoiler alert
he's known that probably since he was 10
or 11. how that works
he's learning how to navigate the adult
world right now
that's what he's learning and it has
zero consequences mom will yell and
she'll get mad
and all you have to do is change the
screen and she'll eventually clean your
room and pick up the food bags
and if she doesn't do that she's going
to make food and put on the counter for
us before she goes to bed
and so what i want you to do anne is you
are going to have to learn to love
differently
because the way you're loving your kids
right now is not helping them it's
harming them
it's drowning them and they have to
learn how to swim
they've got to got to got to got to god
to learn how to swim
my uber recommendation would be to get a
family therapist who would come visit
you at your house
or you demand the entire crew everyone
living in that house
is going to see somebody together and
that you announce to your husband and to
your
your kids i'm making boundaries
you've got 60 days to get out you've got
30 days to get out depend if he's got a
bunch of savings he can get out tomorrow
he's got to go get an apartment and his
apartment's going to be the most
disgusting
gross thing you've ever seen and that
would be his choice
and he may go down a rabbit hole of
pornography and dysregulation
and hopefully he will see the light take
care of himself begin working towards
things
you can start exercising with him you
can do all kinds of things that are
going to
be productive loving behavioral changes
in his life
but just letting him exist like a
like a like a plant that you're just
going to water and feed and yell at but
i'm just going to keep watering if you
it's not doing any favors he's going to
have to get some problems he's going to
have to learn some new muscles and he's
gonna have to grow
up and i know you love him and these are
the hard choices you gotta make he's 24
years old he's a grown man
if he'd been in world war ii he'd
already would have gone to war and been
back
and married and probably have three kids
right he'd have to be back
he'd already have seen the world it's
time for him to grow up all right anne
and it's time for you
to cut those codependent strings on both
of your kids
and let them grow up and be adults thank
you so much for that call
all right um so i got this email here
and then i've got some exciting news
against this email
um this email comes from stephen says
i've been reading the book scattered if
you don't know
the book scattered by gabor mate is a
book that i recommend
anybody struggling with adhd anyone
married to somebody with adhd
anyone who's got adult adhd who's got
kit read
this book it's a masterpiece it's
the best a little wee bit heady it's a
masterpiece
stephen says i've been reading the book
scattered by gabor mate
m-a-t-e we'll link to in the show notes
it's been an emotional rollercoaster of
hell while simultaneously bringing to
light the whys and hows of an adult
of being an adult with adhd i'm looking
for a counselor but that's been hard due
to the pandemic what are some tips and
tricks i can implement in the short term
so you guys have heard me talk about
this right a
a as an adult with adhd too like a
guiding principle of my life
is don't forget to remember i forget all
the time to get the cups out of my truck
i just am on to the next on the next on
the next but i always remember how good
it feels to get in the car
and it's perfectly clean and that
reminds me to take my junk in i remember
how good it feels to have my lunch made
in the morning
right i remember how good it feels when
i get into my bed and it's been made
and so i live by the sentence don't
forget to remember my wife will remind
me
when i'm grabbing a plate of cookies to
go sit down she'll say don't forget to
remember how good you feel tomorrow
when you haven't eaten any of that stuff
if she said quit eating the cookies i'd
be like oh my gosh i'm a girl man i can
never
it would be a whole thing right don't
forget to remember number two
exercise friends and accountability you
gotta move your body you gotta move your
body
walking lifting especially lifting
weights
um if you're a runner do something you
gotta move pull things push things i
don't care what you're doing you gotta
move your body
you gotta take care of your nutrition
you gotta be around other people and you
got to have people in your life that you
can hold that will hold you accountable
that if you skip an evening out with the
with your friends with the guys with the
gals
they'll say hey you can't you're not
skipping again you're coming
right writing making sure you get this
hurricane of thoughts out of your head
and put them down on paper
they tend to loop in the adhd mind they
loop and they loop and they loop
and then they activate your physiology
right they take over your body
get them out and write them down okay
gratitude journals journaling whatever
and then here's the thing you gotta just
do it and you gotta do it you don't feel
like it
i was up late last night at an event
today was
this is sounds so cliche i'm embarrassed
to say this out loud today was like
today was squats and deadlifts you had
to do it man i didn't want to do it i
walked around my garage gym i was like
you got to do it you got to do it you
got to do it because i don't want to
forget to remember how good it feels
when it's done
and then you have a lot of grace with
yourself people around you have to have
grace with you
and they've got to know sometimes you
fall down and they're going to pick you
back up
and they're going to bunk you on the
head and they're going to smile at you
they're going to win catch they're going
to laugh at you they'll laugh with you
and they're going to move on
but here's the cool thing so
before this show i spent two hours two
hours there's a long session with my
counselor i think everybody
needs to be seeing somebody having
somebody they can talk to whether it's a
close friend that will listen to them
whether it's a professional whether it's
a mixture of both right
it was uncomfortable and super super
necessary and hard and important it was
all of it right
one of the most important common
questions right i get
is i'm looking for a counselor how do i
find a counselor what do i need to do
without a counselor
and so i always want folks to you can go
back and look you can just google
the show you can go back and look in the
in the search engine here whether it's
on the podcast or whether it's on
youtube
um how to find a counselor how to find
an in-person counselor
here's the thing it's good for learning
it's good for healing relationships
mental health mental illness how to make
friends healing from trauma all that
stuff
but not everyone has access millions and
millions and millions of people
live in the states that have not opened
back up they don't have enough money to
go see somebody in person
every in-person person's got a waiting
list whatever that might be
right so i'm super excited to let you
know that i've partnered with
better help to offer online therapy
for video phone even uh
live chat interactions dude it is
customized
live therapy not not like
hey bro actual licensed counselors right
and that you can see on your camera it's
just like a
facetime you can't do it you can plug
your your computer in and see it on your
big screen tv at your house
you can do it on your phone or you can
call them and talk to them and sometimes
people are having
a really rough time they can do uh text
chat interactions or on the computer
interactions right
so here's the deal it's much more
affordable than
in-person therapy right much more and
you can start meeting with your
therapist within 48 hours
when you fill this out okay here's a
cool thing millions
and millions of people are doing it and
that's not like we're in middle school
come on bro everybody's doing it
here's the thing i took away your last
excuse if you can't find an in-person
person
go to betterhelp.com slash delony
betterhelp.com deloney
you're going to get 10 off your first
month you can sign up to start seeing
somebody within 48 hours
do it do it now you have no more excuses
do it all right and if you're struggling
with adhd and you
mind is looped out betterhelp.com
deloney and go make it happen all right
let's take one more call let's go to
jesse
in kansas city missouri what's up jesse
how are we doing
hi i'm doing good um
i i have a question for you it's
how do adult children create boundaries
with parents
when they're still siblings at home
give me an example walk me through it
yeah um well
i listened to like some of your shows
that
um well my mom is um
has a lot of narcissistic personality
traits
um and i have a lot of siblings um
five of them are out of the house and
several
more are still living in the house how
many siblings do you have
i have 12 siblings got a girl way to go
dude
that's a that's a whole other show right
yeah
so so five are out and i guess
i'm bad at math but that the rest of
them are at home um
like six more are at home wow okay so
um anyway but with my mom
uh i think me and several of my
other siblings are really struggling
with creating boundaries
um with mainly my mom but also
my parents um and like i've listened to
a lot of your shows where you've given
advice to
you know create boundaries such as you
know we'll have thanksgiving and
christmas without you until you can
figure out
your marriage and in some ways that
applies
and like limiting contact also applies
until i just think about like i can't
leave my siblings
like i can't leave the rest of the ones
at home and
and and i and i feel like lost there
because
you know i feel like whenever i'm
leaving um
or creating boundaries it really goes to
my siblings also are they are your
siblings safe
um yeah okay are they um
being emotionally neglected are they
being beat up what
what are the things what are the things
your mom's doing that says that you are
having to draw a line you cannot be
around me
you can't be around my family um
i i think i've so i've been out of the
house for eight years
um and i've had to go to like tons of
therapy
for myself just to go through a lot of
that stuff um
you're giving me lots and lots of words
what is it about your mom
yeah um she like
you don't know what it's like unless
you're living there
like there's a really good time that's
what i'm trying to ask you
you're so good it's hard because it's
like gosh i haven't worked there for so
long i think that i've forgotten
how bad it is she's really manipulative
but you
you have made the decision i i don't
want my my mom in my life yeah and
i i trust you that's the right decision
all i'm asking you is why have you made
that decision eight years later now i'm
done
she's hurt like me
and like just the words that she used
growing up
um were really hurtful like for a long
time i just
like i wanted to feel loved and a lot of
my siblings
were also struggling with that same
thing and when i lived at home
um i would beg them like i was so
depressed as a teenager
and like um
i just needed help like really badly and
i would go to the hospital with chest
pain
from how much anxiety i had and like we
had
social workers coming in checking on us
um
and you know nothing and we were so
scared like all of us kids we were so
scared about being taken away and
everything we were like the perfect
family but my mom she just she's
emotionally hurtful
um like when i lived there
she would go away to a room for like
days
on end and like my dad is still at home
or he
yeah so my my parents are together and
um and he
didn't like while i was living there he
didn't really have a lot to do
like he kind of checked out he would get
home and take over
house responsibilities and stuff and my
mom would check out and
my dad was just not not there
and so let me tell you let me tell you
this
it is really hard to grow up in the
house of parents
that have mental health issues
because they look normal they
present normal and then they disappear
right
yeah and you feel whispers or ghosts of
the person you think they should be or
that you desperately need them to be and
they're not
and in some ways it feels like it would
be easier if they just weren't there
because there's not that disconnect
between i know they're right in that
room and what is it about me that they
won't even come out of that room to see
their own kid
right it's almost easier if they're just
not there
because they can't come see you because
they're in another state right
yes and um sorry
go ahead um yeah and and it just was
like the only time that they
that my my mom would ever say anything
good about me was like
when i would do something really good
and like she could post it on social
media being like you know look at my
daughter
you know she graduated at the top of her
class and then like that was the only
good thing that was ever said otherwise
like the word she used is i was the
poison of the family
because i was the oldest one living at
home at the time
and i would like beg my parents like can
we please you know we need help like
i don't like my siblings are coming to
me asking for help and i don't know what
to do and you know we need
counseling or family counseling and and
i was just the poison of the family
at that time listen listen listen
they shouldn't have told you that i'm
sorry
no parent should ever tell their kid
that they're poisoned
okay that should never have happened and
i'm sorry that that did
and you're gonna have a two-fold thing
going on here number one
you've got to take care of yourself your
boundaries are yours
nobody else's they're not your brothers
and sisters they're not
um your mom and dad's not your grandpa
they're yours
okay and so you have to develop those
strong boundaries
apologize to no one they are what they
are so that you can function and be
whole and well
okay the second thing is if your brother
and sisters the seven kids still living
in that home
are experiencing what you're
experiencing now then you have an
obligation to call somebody
those are two separate things okay
and
they're just children and unfortunately
it's landed in your lap
and you've got to make that i think
i think you know that i don't know
i don't i don't know okay um if you're
listening so surreal it is and
you're in the middle of it and
if it blows up everything that won't be
your fault you will have helped solve
an issue that's been ongoing for years
and years and years and years
okay okay and
if your brothers and sisters are being
neglected for days on end
if they are calling you crying saying
help help help
then yeah you've got to help that's a
that's what a big sister does that's
what a community member does you got to
make that phone call
and if your dad can hear it then you
start with
him and say i'm giving this one month
now i'm going to call social worker
get the kids because i'm not doing that
i do i do have something about that
um my my dad
um my dad
sorry my one of my other brothers who's
also out of the house
took my dad out to breakfast because
my mom was concerned about his mental
health and so was my brother
and and then my dad kind of revealed
like this huge pretty much his disgust
with my mom and their marriage and
everything and absolutely
um and he's also dealing with a lot of
mental health
um issues and and that's part of
why this became a thing now um
like for me specifically is because i am
concerned about my siblings
um like jesse jesse
like you can't fix your mom and dad
you can't you can never achieve your way
to being loved by them there's not a
right way to make this
call there's not a right way to tell
them i don't want you all in my life for
the next
season while i heal there's not a
there's not a way to do that that they
can hear it and be like that's cool we
get it
they can't they're not well
and your whole life has been about
making sure
they leave you alone that they are okay
so you can go about doing your thing
even to the point that you gave up your
thoughts and your dreams
and the things you want to do so you
could get the right grades so your mom
could post the right thing about her
poisoned daughter
right right and eight years out of that
house you're
still living in it still and you have
these imaginary conversations
over and over about if i could just sit
down and say this
and not say that and right am i crazy no
that's right
and it's exhausting
and you are poisoning yourself every day
hoping that they die and that's just not
going to work that way
i think i wonder to myself like
is it even the right thing to call
someone because
like i just have it in my head like and
people
i've i've talked to people since then
they're like well you know
most of you guys have turned out fine so
far you know
it's you hey jesse you're not fine
and you know that you are really really
good at performing
you're good at it academy award level
you're not fine
right right
just thinking about how your mom talked
to you
opens a wound up right it's right there
at the surface you've done a lot of
therapy so you can get through a day and
have normal relationships and friends
you're not okay
what would that look like for my
siblings
every every single situation is
different that's why this is
messy and i want you to be under no
illusions that this is a simple thing
do you get with the other five brothers
and sisters and say hey we're all gonna
have to figure this out
we're gonna take have a group call here
because i'm not letting this happen
or do you meet with your mom and dad
together and say if y'all don't start
seeing somebody and getting medicated
and started getting well
i'm gonna do what i can to get these
kids out of this house
and it may look like those kids going
two of them going to one brother and one
of them going to one sister
here's the thing there is not a way that
this isn't messy going forward
it's messy if you don't say anything
then that cycle continues it's messy if
you
blow the whole thing up and call the
child protective services of your state
or area and they come in
swarming it's messy if you call a social
worker who says
we're gonna teach your mom and dad and
get them the help they need it's
messy just regardless and i hate this
for you
you didn't ask for this you don't
deserve this but it just is
and you should not be having to do this
by yourself you should have brothers and
sisters who
know exactly what your other ones what
their siblings are going through
and they do is that right oh yeah we
actually we've had a little meeting
this year already to discuss my dad's
mental health
okay so and i just think that
it just feels i don't want to say
extreme because i i don't know if it's
extreme or not but to call social
services on my
own parents and to um you know
and my siblings living there like
they'll do normal activities too
but you you just don't hear like it's
just not spoken
of unless you know
like my my youngest or one of my younger
brothers
living at home saw my dad sitting on the
bed with a gun
just because my dad was suicidal at the
time and like that's just stuff i don't
want my siblings to go through
jesse nope jesse listen
do you hear the words coming out of your
mouth
you gotta make that call and you
probably got to get all your brothers
and sisters together and you all have to
decide together this is going to be the
weekend we do this
and if your dad hauls off and takes his
own life that is not on you
it's not if your mother says see i told
you so after all these years that's not
on you
if they uncover all sorts of things with
interviewing your brothers and sisters
it's just a mess and it may be that your
dad is begging begging begging begging
for
somebody to reach out and say hey you're
not okay let's get you the help you need
let's get you somewhere it may be that
your mom is begging begging begging
here's the thing you can't solve your
mom and dad's problems they have to
decide they want to get well
but if you've got underage kids in that
house
walking in on your dad holding a gun you
can't you got to step in
you got to make that call you have to
okay jesse i hate this for you i hate
this for your brothers and sisters i
hate this for
anybody who is trying to stop
generational or
legacy abuse and emotional trauma and
trying to love their parents through
mental illness
it's so hard it's devastating tears upon
tears
loss of sleep but that doesn't mean it's
not the right thing
what i want you to do is to go see i
want you before you make any phone calls
i want you
jesse to go call somebody
whether that's an online therapist
whether it's an in-person therapist i
want you to go meet with somebody and
say
i'm gonna weigh in here the time has
come for me to weigh in and it's going
to be hard and i i want you to get a
game plan with a professional therapist
then call in your brothers and sisters
and say here's the game plan here's what
we're going to do
and then somebody's going to volunteer
and say we're going in
we're going to sit down with mom and dad
and say here's what's about to happen
and we're going to get the kids out of
that house and we're going to split them
up among the brothers and sisters until
things are well
or we're going to call services or y'all
are going to commit to x y or z dad
you're going to get committed mom you
have to step up
this is not y'all's house to run but
those kids need somebody to step in and
advocate for them they need an ally
soon today because you know why you
needed that too
and i hate the fact that nobody showed
up for you jesse i hate it i hate it i
hate it
and now's your chance you and your
brothers and sisters to turn and face
this forest fire that's raging through
your family and say no more
we're done we don't even know how this
is gonna look and it's gonna be a
disaster
but we're turning we're going to face
this thing down no more
let me know how that goes let me know
that session goes live and how that
conversation goes
do not think this is going to be easy
this is the hardest thing you ever had
to do
that doesn't mean it's not right often
the hardest things we have to do are
the righteous things we have to do thank
you so much for being brave jesse and
for that call
man that one's tough man my heart goes
out to you guys we'll be thinking about
you jesse
all right as we wrap up today's show um
man i love this song i'm not even gonna
introduce it i'm just gonna go from here
off the 2009 backspacer album it's a
sleeper record and it's so good
it's so good
it's called just breathe by pearl jam it
goes like this
yes i understand that every life must
end
as we sit alone i know someday we must
go i'm a lucky man to count on both
hands
the ones i love some folks just have one
and others they got none
stay with me let's just breathe i
practiced all my sins never gonna let me
win
under everything just another human
being i don't want to hurt and there's
so much in this world to make me bleed
to stay with me
you're all i see did i say that i need
you did i say that i want you
if i didn't i'm a fool you see no one
knows this more than me
i wonder every day as i look upon your
face everything you gave and nothing you
would take
nothing you would take in everything you
gave
did i say that i need you did i say that
i want you if i didn't i'm a fool
no one knows this more than me this is
the dr john delony
[Music]
show